in Dark Souls 2 you lose a little bit of
your humanity and a little bit of your
maximum health with each death
eventually you overcome the obstacle
that stood between you and victory but
your game does not come without
sacrifice you have forfeited your own
humanity as you collect the souls of the
Damned like Dark Souls and Demon's Souls
before it Dark Souls 2 is not just a
fantasy role-playing adventure but a
phenomenal exploration of dread few
games make you this afraid to peer
around the corner while simultaneously
curious as to what incredible new Vista
you might gaze upon and death is so very
beautiful in this game for it comes at
the hands of hulking armored Knights and
otherworldly invaders welcome to
drangleic a world that makes you ask
many questions and then expects you to
go seeking the answers Dark Souls 2
offers you an early taste of hope
however in the hub area known as medulla
while medulla is mostly devoid of life
when you first come upon it it slowly
fills out with the vendors you meet upon
your travels your most important contact
there is the cloaked woman who levels
you up in exchange for souls the game's
currency as with its predecessors there
are no waypoints and there is no quest
log instead you simply head out into
drangleic seeking to light primal
bonfires and thus restore some dignity
to this decrepit land the basics are
very similar to those of Demon Souls and
Dark Souls you defeat enemies in brutal
and precise combat collect their souls
and spend those souls on levels
equipment and more if you die you lose
the souls you were carrying and have one
chance to retrieve them should you die
again those souls are gone some of the
differences between Dark Souls and Dark
Souls 2 are noticeable early on for
instance
usually when you die or rest at a
bonfire the world is refreshed and the
standard enemies you killed respawn but
in Dark Souls 2 there comes a point at
which many enemies in the area just
don't respawn
on anymore allowing you freedom to
progress with fewer obstacles in yourway
at first you might worry that this
change and others might soften the
game's edge but the grinding
opportunities are still there
Dark Souls two's main hook though is the
promise of new and exciting places to
explore and new and exciting foes to
face and that hook is supported by a
number of subtle changes to the formula
for example once you activate a bonfire
you can warp to it from any other
bonfire without having to pass through
perilous places over and over again and
the excitement of finding an item that
in turn unlocks a new area is a far
greater thrill than grinding for Souls
the early forests and ruins are so very
dark souls but the intricate
architecture and carefully planned enemy
locations make even familiar looking
environments fresh and unique the more
progress you make however the more
unusual and awesome the settings become
though the lighting is somewhat flat the
settings are often incredible Dragons
soar in the skies castles loom in the
background and glowing sunsets give you
the slightest smidgen of hope and so
Dark Souls 2 is hard but is it harder
than the original not quite nor are the
bosses as awesome to look at as SIF or
the gaping dragon but the bosses are
still visually inventive and the game
offers plentiful challenge trudging your
way through shin deep water while
avoiding homing missiles is no easy task
just as before help comes from other
players as well as from the game itself
all Dark Souls 2 players are intertwined
in a comforting web of communication as
before you see the spirits of other
players as they journey through their
own worlds and if you feel truly
cooperative you can avail yourself to
other players who can summon you in for
assistance you can also hinder other
players by invading their worlds just as
before though certain additions to
online play keep battles more dynamic
than ever for instance if you use a
particular item monsters turn on your
enemies luring an invader into a trap is
an
absolute delight there's so so so much
more to talk about with Dark Souls 2
there's the fantastic stretch near the
end of the game that involves you in
grander battles then you would expect
from this series then there are the
covenants fellowships that bond you with
other players and give you more tools to
assist or annihilate each other how some
of these covenants may change the very
feel of the game is still unclear at
this early stage but there's one thing
you can count on Dark Souls 2 is a big
fantastic and satisfying game and a
worthy successor to one of the best RPGs
ever made
you